it's Disney sticking by the all-new very
blue genie or as the house of mouse
already denouncing its own creation the
company kept quiet after the internet
completely torched Will Smith following
the newest live-action Aladdin trailer
drop but now Disney has come forward to
address the blue Genie debacle it wasn't
long ago that Disney summoned up the
second trailer for its upcoming
live-action remake of Aladdin an updated
version of the 1992 animated classic
from director Guy Ritchie but the very
vocal responds to the trailer from
online viewers may have caught studio
executives off-guard especially the
reaction to the Genie reveal money shot
some people must have liked it but the
consensus seemed clear in addition to
the new face of the genie the sneak
peeks of movie have brought audiences
their first glimpses of fresh-faced
actor Meena Masood as Aladdin the
scrappy street rat who sweeps a royal
princess off her feet with the help of a
few white lies and the magic flying
carpet about Princess Jasmine is being
played by Naomi Scott you may recognize
from the cast of the 2017 Power Rangers
movie the previews for the movie have
also offered loads of the fictional city
of Agrabah as well as a glimpse of
Marwan ken sari as a movie's nefarious
Grand Vizier Jaffar perhaps the most
recognizable it's a glittering Cave of
Wonders and the ever-important golden
lamp that sits within it but much so
many people's dismay the most terrifying
image from the second sneak peak is a
brief kind of I can never unsee that
moment of actor Will Smith as a genie a
blue skinned magical being who looks
bluer in real life that anyone could
have thought possible fewer responses
were not great after the internet
dragged Smith and the remakes new genie
look Disney kept quiet what might happen
now that the company knew people were
rejecting as important investments will
they address the hate or keep their lips
sealed until the movie came out did they
tweak their approach to the genei maybe
by making him look a little bit more
real that remains to be seen but for now
the company has come forward to at least
address the big blue genie debacle in a
statement released the USA Today a
little over a week after the second
teaser saw release Disney defend its
Miss Genie in broad terms without
getting into the specifics of viewers
shocked reactions reactions that range
from that look scary or that looks fake
to oh wow that's
yes the company attempted to be the bad
birds by affirming his confidence in
both the new interpretation of the genie
character and the live-action Aladdin
project as a whole the statement read we
have one of the most anticipated films
of the year and a confident that
audiences will fall in love with the
genie and all of the other characters
when it hits the big screen this may
it's not exactly a shocker that Disney
is sticking to its guns or Smith's genie
it'd be more surprising if they actually
agreed with the criticism what else they
supposed to do cancel the movie despite
the lousy first reactions one of the
film's main characters there's plenty of
Aladdin that we've simply yet to see
meaning there's also hope that the genie
could work just fine in context so long
as people are still willing to give the
movie a shot but considering all the
skepticism in the air around these
teasers that's no guarantee but their
audiences are hype for it or nuts the
film's creative team is likely putting
all available resources into ensuring
the live-action Aladdin as a shining
shimmering and splendid as it possibly
can be
it's just a project with a lot to live
up to especially for Smith taking over a
role first embodied by the late
larger-than-life Robin Williams it's
possible that audiences were going to
judge Smith harshly no matter what
approach the filmmakers took holding his
performance to a high standard whether
the effects looked flawless or not the
former Fresh Prince has enormous shoes
to fill but you can't say that he's not
trying as he said in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly I got to sing I got
to rap I got to dance I got to do action
sequences it was everything that I've
trained and learned how to do over the
last 30 years of entertainment and I got
to use it all in playing the genie maybe
the genies weird looks will keep people
from getting on board with the remake or
maybe the world would be as charmed as
Princess Jasmine on a magic carpet ride
to find out what happens we'll simply
have to wait until Aladdin arrives in
theaters on May 24th check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about weird genies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]